hey guys what's up this is andrew from
jensens.com so
day number 10 for me today in my
crunching hotel
and i have to say that it starts to be a
little bit boring guys i'm here sitting
alone all day
but hopefully you are here so you are
the reason why i'm waking up
every morning guys to give you an amc
update
so let's get into it yes
so what did we have yesterday was a red
day guys some uh
bearish move happened so in my previous
video this was totally expected so once
again i had a few scenarios
i have some of you by the way that in
the comments uh you know
saying yeah basically you have three
scenarios one going up one going out
down one going sideways
but guys you know this is what is
training all right you always have
different scenarios with different
associated probabilities
but you have some triggers that tell you
if you're heading to scenario 1 or
scenario 2 or sna3
during the trading sessions and this is
how you actually
use technical analysis to set up your
trades this is not an exact science
i i cannot know for sure what will
happen exactly you know i'm just
building different scenarios
and i'm following them and this is very
helpful to
actually enter for example long position
or to
take some profits stuff like this this
is what i'm doing just for those who
don't really understand so here for
example this is a very
nice level guys and i told you this
yesterday in my discord
to enter a long position so once again
no financial advice here only my view
guys this is what i
would do here i would be a buyer and
let me explain to you exactly the
reasons behind
and how to enter this trade i'm gonna
basically go through here all the
different signals that we're having and
i'm gonna see if they're bullish or
bearish and then i'm gonna set up the
situation and give you my different
scenarios
so here i remind you guys the first
signal that we have is this trendline
all right
look how this is acting so you just
connect i'm giving you
guys here some very good tips just
connect the highs all right here here
you can see this one i'm not touching
perfectly
it's fine because i have more reactions
one more here
and here i can see so this was the first
time i told you guys that we're gonna
have some rejection here
we had and then we blew right through it
with
high associative volume which is
confirming that this is a breakout that
many traders are using it
so once the breakout is confirmed then
you ninety percent of the time
have a retest and this is the reason why
i told you guys don't formal here
all the area between 38 40 here we could
be rejected so it was not the right time
to buy
here it was just pure formal so it was
of course not the right time to buy
and now it's the time to buy from you
because now we're having
the beautiful retest of this trend line
and
it's not only that guys the 37 level
it's also another level that i told you
about yesterday in my video guys it's
the typical
retracement level of a zigzag so we had
the zigzag which was my second scenario
of yesterday's scenario and typically
those
zigzags they like to retrace the 50 or
61.8
retracement level of fibonacci of the
previous move up
or down it works in both ways of course
and here it's 37 right so we had the
reaction here
so this is to me first signal breakout
all right on the daily strong breakout
second
information the fee retracement level at
37
37 was also guys a support level that
you can have
you see here guys once again the recent
past is the best
so of course here you have 38
so i was talking about 28 as well but 38
didn't hold and the next one
then you can see it's here you have some
highs here one high
here it's already put it perfectly here
one two three
so in the past week you had one two
three
four five six seven
seven reactions before coming here and
here one two three
four already all right so total 11
reactions in the past week so this is a
very
strong support guys that i told you once
again so there is no guarantee we gotta
hold but there is a 18 90
chance that we strongly bounce back from
here guys so this is my first scenario
of course that we bounce back here with
a high probability
what does do we have guys here we also
have
so i told you guys this already the
bullish divergences so you can see the
macd going higher
bam and the market was here going lower
all right so we can stop it here so we
have this
buddhist divergence that is impacting
the price action for roughly the same
period of
the time between the loads so here okay
so basically it's gonna stop diffusing
here but it's once to twice
so okay so this bullish divergence is
not impacting the price action that
much anymore to be honest but we're
still having it
it's still good to see those uh in the
moves down then another information very
important guys
is that here look we moved doing five
waves one two
three four five so what are our
different scenarios
here either we're having a one two three
four five like i showed you guys or
you know this is not an abc okay
you can see it's not an abc right but we
could have a bigger abc
which suggests that anyway even if we
are to correct
lower so this is my second scenario even
if we had to current lower we would
still go higher from here
and then we would complete this wave
counting guys
okay
all right and then we would go to
revisit the lows probably 224 and this
would be
maybe you know i don't like to see five
waves going down guys because
just for the same reason i don't like to
see five waves going up
i like to see five waves going up
because i know there's going to be an
abc correction and they're at again five
waves if we have five waves going down
it's not
good guys it's not good it suggests that
we have an abc and then five waves again
so we're not there yet maybe i can find
another accounting that is giving me
another scenario but
i wouldn't like to see a rejection here
if we have a small rejection it's fine
you know
so let me go back to the first scenario
okay here it's totally fine to have
something like this
okay even something deeper all right i
don't know maybe the one is going to be
the smaller the three like this
you know so it's totally fine to have a
rejection here we expect a rejection
here there's going to be a rejection 90
percent of
probability that if we go from 37 to 50
guys
especially that quickly we gonna have
here a rejection so it's a nice
profit-taking area i know you guys don't
like that but i'm just
giving you day trading tips here so
third
information we have five waves here then
another information
you can see yes i have this rsi so you
know
it's an rsi strategy i i don't usually
use this but you know sometimes i want
to use rsi and i put a rsi strategy it's
this one
and it's giving me it's funny to look at
those because it's giving me the over uh
sold and over both areas
and here i had another sold area so
giving me a signal
move up later and then here it's just
interesting to notice that i have one
more once again
we can have a look at all the signals in
the past and you can see for example you
combine it by two you buy here you sell
here okay good you buy here you sell
here
you're not making me not losing you buy
here you sell here you make you make you
buy here
sell higher buy here sell lower so here
you lose a bit
by here so here flat by yourself here
you lock
loss here so it's working maybe 70
of the time and of course in term of
profits you're missing the big profits
and you're taking the big losses for
example here you would have bought
in may at 12 and sold at 14 guys and you
would have missed all of this of course
it's not
a good strategy to use by itself but
it still gives 70 percent a round of
winners even if the losers
take all the profits from the winners
it's still 70 percent of winners
so as i have one signal here the
probability will go higher
from here is to me 70 just according to
this
on top of that i have my breakout i have
my five waves up
i have my bullish divergence here so
what can i say guys
i'm of course here very bullish then
it's always good to look at the past
guys i want to show you something here
look we are a bit in this situation i
showed you already some comparison with
this area here we were
moving doing five ways up doing the huge
breakout here
same situation guys all right this was
just before we three you connect the
high
the high and you can see it's you know
technical analysis is actually good
because you can see here
so we move higher sorry we get rejected
first
then we break it and then what happens
oh interesting correction correction to
the trend line all right
correction to the breakout trend line
and you can see guys it's
also interesting to see that it didn't
hold it should have hold here
once again guys i'm showing you this
example many times but i think it's very
interesting
it should have hold at the 61.8 which
was around the 10 level all right
the 975 level something like this okay
it should have hold
so it's even higher it's here guys okay
and what happened here so we are here
in this situation what happened here
guys we broke it and just
kept going lower this was to me you know
very
very very big trick that was here given
us by the
market so where is my tool
okay this stuff guys
you guys like to talk about action
manipulation this
was probably one i don't know what it is
you know it's just defining all the
usual rules that i'm having so you just
learn from
the past and here what i can say is that
there is 80
probability we bounce back today i can
also say
that in some cases we have some excess
just like we had before
so careful the next support level is 35.
so of course i'm a buyer between 37
and 40 like i said yesterday because
this retest was expected
but i'm careful about some tricks here
guys so maybe the 3537
area would be tested in the for this
friday trading session and i would still
be a buyer of course
guys the whole way down all right if we
need to go here then we go here
it's of course not my preferred scenario
but it's something that can happen
okay we can still hover a bit here and
then strongly about back it's
of course possible but it's unlikely for
me we're gonna bounce back right away
this is my view for today and i'm gonna
try to post this before the open
as many of you are asking and then yeah
we're gonna discuss later what's gonna
happen in this area but expect here's
some sending uh pressure
and expect to break out as well during
the third wave and expect to go
here guys to the highs if i'm correct
about this counting i think this whole
correction is an abc that is complete
guys a strong abc
and that right now we're moving higher
this is my view this is my preference
scenario
once again i'm gonna post as every day
gme and amc daily recaps guys in my
discord just come and join it still for
free until next week
and yeah i'm posting there all the
information that i think that i think
are interesting during the day
so i'm doing my best to you know guide
you through my experience of how to you
know
enter your trades or you know just
answer any questions that you're having
i'm very happy to do this actually
especially here because i have nothing
else to do so i'm very happy to answer
all of your questions
and thank you so much guys for your
support thank you so much for watching
this video
so if you enjoyed it please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
so stay close to show guys